so scott
scott uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally i'm originally from
maine
it's where i wished i would have been
able to grow up my father was an air
force so
we traveled overseas mostly when i was a
kid
what kind of childhood yeah it was great
until my dad
had to leave to korea he was in the air
force
um you know career
and my mom divorced him in the midwest
and i
was not having that you know
i mean especially living overseas like
philippines
i like adventure and nebraska was not
adventurous so i left
i got in trouble when i was 12 and just
left
but it was more or less my mom wanted me
to go
it wasn't like i was ended up on the
streets because of choice
but because of uh
rejection what kind of trouble are you
getting into
really nothing illegal i just wasn't
going to school
i couldn't read or write at the time or
do math or any of that stuff
there was nothing the only thing that i
could had any contact with
were animals and that was strange to my
family so
well with my mother and my brother my
sister who was doing good there from
another dad
which makes them you know fortunate
because the dad i have had
problems and i can't carry it on to me
and it bothered me a lot and i wanted to
hide that
and running away was my way of
hiding what i really am
you know and it hurt you know i didn't
want people to know i couldn't learn
and but uh
i was 12 that was in 76. you ran away at
12
yeah so how far did you get in school
oh i didn't have a grade i wasn't
special ed
you know i literally couldn't read or
write until i was 17 at least
and it was hitchhiking through different
cities and states
and seeing this you know welcome to the
state of california that it just caught
and but when you go
that far and then you finally learn it's
already too late
you know you're going to end up being a
lifer like this
you've been on the street for how long
76
to 2018
so that's quite a long time i think yeah
and
i started getting little rooms like
15 by 15 rooms with just a
you know a bathroom that's in the
hallway and
but i i'm i was too uh
i'm like you know if i'm gonna pay to
live in a room
because at first i wasn't on ssi and i
should have been on
ssi for years before i ever got onto it
but
i just just didn't care about anything
and i don't know where you want to go
with this but
i ended up in la i was 14 i was in 78.
and being that you do remember
i don't talk too much about it but i've
had enough
of people who look like they're normal
and i was at this place called
okie dogs where there was punk rockers
and everything and i didn't really know
what up
what was going on and then one friday
night
[Music]
i got picked up by the la freeway killer
and that happened to be a really bad
experience
that night on and i was on lsd
and um wherever i jumped out of the car
it was in some place called
rosemead and to this day i don't know
where that is
but or how far it was for milky dogs in
hollywood
but um i jumped out of the car ran into
a
um there was a church and there was a in
an alley and i jumped down in the
window that was like in the basement but
it was like a little spot and i just
stayed there
until daylight and some girls some
girl was going to school and saw me and
i was bloody and everything and she
gave me money and i said where are you
from i'm from hollywood and
you know and i went back to hollywood
and i
and that very day i got a mohawk and i
wanted to look like the most
scariest evilest thing because uh
the only people that seemed like it was
cool to me
were people that looked like they
weren't cool
you know that was that's a different era
you know
than what you see today now people who
look like
name cool aren't cool but that's my own
opinion
but um so the dad that raised you was
your my stepdad and who i really
admire and respect but you're you're
your actual father
no he i never knew him
um do you know anything about him i knew
that he had the same learning problems
same like i have a problem with my back
and it's all pretty much genetic and
um i didn't like my posture it made me
feel like
i couldn't hit on girls so i really
really was
the only friends that i had were
basically
pets you know rats
particularly i like rats because they
were the farthest thing that
any human being really cared about but i
saw myself in rats
is that an animal you relate to yeah i
still have them
to this very day but
years later and like in 88
87 when they they had this big homeless
thing about tent city and sf
and every news camera people
acro in the world was there filming
and um i was like you know the way i
stand out now
is the way i stood out then and they
were running to me
and it kind of gave me a little
self-esteem
about who i am being homeless you know
um i would hitchhike
i didn't really go to big cities because
i was scared
and but i didn't know how to
survive really well either i wouldn't
carry a sleeping bag or a blanket
because i didn't want people to know i
was homeless
and it was really
screwed up you know and
now that i am not off the street but uh
if you want the effect is still there
you know and
and i try real hard to turn it off you
know
and i've been learning a little bit you
know i'm i'm
self-taught i built my computer i wrote
a book
um i'm trying to do positive things but
there's
other things in my life that's really
um it's like uh
it's like i'm on hold you know just like
this
thing that's going on right now with the
with everything being stopped
in the city and around the country
that's the way i feel
every day anyways i feel like i'm in a
prison
as a matter of fact i've been to prison
and i was
freer on the inside than i have ever
been on the outside
and
i've been pretty solid though i've never
done anything that i for
anything that i wouldn't want to do
just so i could get something
you know are drugs a part of your life
yes i smoke crystal
um not a lot but
at least
um if you were to say if you're smoking
a cigarette and you take
four or five hits every day off a
cigarette and then put it out
that's about where i'm at now it used to
be i was
i started doing intravenous drugs in
um 84 when i came up here from l.a
because in l.a the olympics was going on
the cops was not
cool and i came up here and the scene
was really jumping off
and um i got introduced to uh
shoot and speed i was 20 years old
and uh um
i never thought that i used to tell
myself that i was never going to stay in
this city
more than a year because i would never
leave after that
and that i'd never
stay up more than two days
and i wouldn't do it more than twice a
week
but it ended up being real quick like
doing it every day except for two
um for months
and then i then i eventually did leave
and i didn't go through any culture
shock until after 2000.
i had already been here so many years
that
wherever i went after here
the world is just so big and you know
this city you can get
anything and do anything within a three
block radius
and i feel like this is my turf there
isn't a person in the city that
cannot say they don't know the red men
that's what they call me
red men you know and um
and i enjoy that but i also
want to also want to get it together
i don't know what that world is like i
mean
i know a lot of good people musicians
from la you know anaheim you know
oxnard area ventura and all of that and
you know they support me but you know
i'm just a different kind of person and
tired of feeling that way you know and
uh
have you always felt like an outcast
yeah i mean it
a matter of fact i even feel like uh
as far as hardcore goes
like a biker or punk rocker to me it
seems like
none of them has me out beat but
you know when you're 56
you do think a lot and i do think a lot
and i
don't discredit how smart i really am
i was learned a different way you know
but it kind of sucks that the way i
learn
it scroll screws me up you know
as far as being able to use it unless i
get lucky
you know what do you do for money now
how do you support yourself
well i get social security and um
my rent i got there's a thing called
section 8
that um i finally got after many of
years
and
that makes my rent down to like 200 a
month
and one thing i used to dream about is i
always wanted a room with the view
of the skyline because i loved this city
and and i actually got a view
of the skyline with a full kitchen
full shower bedroom and but yet
it's still hard to
there's a lot of things that living to
live
normal is very uh is still a learning
process
after two years i'm still having
problems
you know realizing that you gotta do
your dishes
you gotta you gotta mop your floor and
you know but would you describe yourself
as happy
no no
i'm uh i'm actually
very very i've even been labeled as
super depressed and
um on you know they
they call me dual diagnoses depression
but the level that i'm on is a very
low level with
on top of uh over excessive
um thinking you know
um and also i got ptsd
because of uh uh
you know i don't care this you know and
understand what this video is about but
i used to have a lot of rats
over
over a couple hundred in my apartment
and and that
was the only thing that made me happy
but
because of that i got in trouble with
the city
and they forced me to kill
a lot of them and i go through a lot of
post
depression over that because they're
they're a wonderful animal
they're they're misunderstood
and that's the way i feel about myself
you know one time i was in an elevator
in a building
when i was still homeless wearing
i had a punk rock jacket into was but
studs and spike but it was a mother and
her child
and for some reason the lady had the
balls to say
excuse me i don't mean to disrespect you
but have this
has anybody ever told um um said to you
that you look like you scare all women
and children
and that kind of never really left my i
never forgot that
but what i really wanted to tell the
lady was
and i think i did i told her it says no
if you really look you'll see
you'll see me you see you see
the the you know
i think pretty much that if you were
going to do art
then i'm then i try to make everything
into art
even the way i look you know i'm sure
that's the way anybody does
whether it just be wearing a suit and
not even like to do that if i ever had
the money but man you'd have to be a lot
of money because i won't wear no cheap
[ __ ]
but i
haven't lost my mind or gone
off the wall and
i love the police i have i
i can look anybody in the eye
you know you know and not have any
any any trip and
talking to you now whereas when i was a
kid
i'm okay with where i'm at what i'm at
but
then again i'm not okay because i
do smoke and i do think
you know i'm i'm not fulfilling
the dream that i can make
um best of you know with what i got
now and i never and 57
56 years of not um
at least trying makes me feel like
that i'm going to go to my grave the way
i am and that just kills me so bad
it really does man i feel like i need to
hit a lottery or something
to come up or you know do something
but you know but you know then again i
realized
i have money in my pocket every day i
got over a hundred dollars in my pocket
now that i just
don't use so i couldn't imagine myself
having a million dollars
and it being any different because of my
situation
you know what's your biggest fear
my biggest fear is uh
this might trip you up
and it is my biggest fear and that is
going to my grave
without having jesus
in my life if you could understand that
for whatever
reason that's where i'm at and
right now i do not feel like i'm there i
do not
feel like i am an image
that is mirrored from my creator
and that really bothers me bad
you know i destroy the temple my body
you know and
you know it's just you know
i'm not living you know a life that's
just
you know day-to-day you know just live
like
you know you're supposed to you know
regardless if i'm
poor or not you know i'm just you know
i'm still using
sometimes i drink but uh
it only lasts for about a couple weeks
every three months because i just um
whatever but i'm never broke and for
some reason after being here so many
years
there's not a person who doesn't know me
which is
it can be good but then the bad thing
about it is
i never have to buy anything and that
that kind of is
not good for me if i want to really want
to try to be free
and like i said the only time i've ever
been free was when i was in prison
that's because everything that i was i
had to do in prison
was basically uh you know
forced upon me you know can't do drugs
in that place
when you could but i wasn't trying to
and i miss uh being happy
like i was when i was in prison
but then i miss a lot of other things
too but mostly my
i'm not happy um
i'm i got a brother and sister that are
millionaires
and to ask for a cpu for my computer
because my cpu just burnt out i took it
out because i had a
radiator in my computer that was 23
years old from an old alienware
and the damn thing just overheated my
cpu
and i can't even get three or 400 bucks
for a new
i7 processor you know and that hurts
you know especially when i got a sister
that's got 11 muscle cars
of her choice you know and you know my
brother's got an olympic swimming pool
i can't get a simple processor from my
computer that can help me
keep myself busy you know that's
that kind of bothers me and also
can be a little um reason why i
continue to mess up and use you know
but i'm still
really pretty solid people you know
that's rare in this city
and then and in l.a
do you feel like you were ever loved
do you feel like you were ever loved as
a child or never
the only thing that
um that
uh i know is that i had a stepdad that
i looked up to looked forward to him
coming home looked forward to going
to a new country or something you know
that was fun
you know but that was up until i was 11.
and then he had to go to korea and then
my mom divorced him in between that
and i didn't want the divorce
but i um but who knows i still might
have ended up on the streets
i don't know i don't know what would
have happened but i know that my real
father when i found out that
some of my learning and my back you know
being
screwed up you know
can be which i know for a fact is
because of
finding out who my real brother and my
real sister is
i mean the brother and sister i have now
from my step-dad are my half-brother and
sister
from my mom but i have another dad i
didn't know that's in maine
when he died but when i found out that
some of these
problems i have can be genetic i became
murderous
because even when i was a kid even
though i wasn't
able to learn education
i still knew something was wrong
and i knew that i was cursed it was like
a curse
because how could somebody be like that
and
and not just say well change and
you know i couldn't do it
and um now that when i think i can
um it's kind of like seems like it's too
late
too late to ever have children do you
like to uh
i don't know i just hope it ain't too
late
to uh make peace with my creator
that's the the only important thing
because there's nothing
in this world that
that i take pleasure in nothing anymore
and i mean my friends and everything all
of that
but then again you know
you know it's just the way it is you
know
um but
and the funny thing is is after i
learned how to read
and write every time i write
or text or anything on facebook
whether it be my brother and sister who
did learn how to read and write
i write something that really makes
sense
and can be a little long and they just
say well
the weather's hot everybody's fine
i hope you're doing good i love you
and if i would have known that that's
all reading and writing was all about
then i probably would have learned when
i was a kid because that's sure now like
what i call you know
you know whatever communication
communication
yeah social skills and that's
one thing i really have a lot of
yes you do but i do have i will say one
thing though about
the way people in the city are a lot of
homeless people that have been here
just as long as i have
and that is they will never forget me
they've told me that i'm one of the few
people that they ever
think of and one of the few people they
say
that uh is solid
a lot of people are not solid or good to
them
to themselves or to their friends
it's all about cake cake cake you know
and i'm glad i don't have that on my
show you know
on my jacket you know you know
all right well red man thank you so much
for talking with me yeah i'm great
talking to you yeah so glad we met
yeah thank you
you